cracket Top Line of veneers McAn and the veteran
Jordan Everly and here we go with the home opener
Le and prco on defense that's tipped in by bavage
Robert Thomas in the for check along with kyou
picked up by bavage centered that's blocked by
the goenda at the line in for gour he goes wide
on goal and a save by Bennington he's down and a
good stop there on Yanni G the wild get it back
and will borget who's out of St Cloud State into
the Zone Alexia right in and Bennington a great
save on [Applause] C Standing Tall here big save
Blue's on the locked away centered again at the
line Alexia he dust it off the borgan shoots it
right on goal and a save by Bennington another
shot by Alexia that's blocked out High got a piece
or not Jamie maybe you had a better look than I
did yeah it looked like he maybe got a piece of
it tough angle down here too now it is dor stren
turning the former jacket that shot block dooman
at the line he dusts it off now shoots it and a
screen shot and a save by Bennington Center
Qui shot by borren they bang away and covered
by benington tied up by Everly now Everly former
first rounder by Edmonson that's the line Marson
a shot Dave Bennington now Vince Don right on goal
and again a save by the Richman Hill onario NATO
PIR puts it in front that's blocked by Bennington
at the line done another shot to score that might
have been tipped in front and the Kracken with
a one nothing lead our good friend Vince Dunn
operating low to high here one timer I don't
know if the Kraken forward gets a stick on
it or if he interferes with Jordan Benning stick
right there we see the stick Nick the Blocker of
Jordan Bennington look at right there I don't know
if Craig Brew I think he's going to challenge this
guys M might have hit his stick [Music] Jamie S
Lewis is challenging the play for gender air first
yeah that's what appeared to happen as McAn with
the War Room in Toronto to make this determination
if it is goalie interference well when you take
a look here the stick gets right inside here the
blocker after coach's challenge it has
been determined that there was goal tender
interfer holding the grip cage a little
bit we'll see what uh what develops with
that and the Kracken Hammer one to Center KN KN
by McAn he comes in and mccan hit the goal post
a short-handed chance and he rifles it off
the post and Thomas back in Thomas waiting
and he drills it just wide of the goal and the
Kraken with 47 seconds left in their power play
to begin the second period as they win the face
off it here is Schwarz for Yamamoto to the back
for Vince dun and dun the former blue for Bor
strand stop shoots it and he scores not sure if
it was tipped or not it's a power play goal
one- nothing [Music] Seattle added here bin
stun moving the puck and watching front of the
net jamen Schwarz purposely purposely showing
his stick to B Str showing him where to shoot
it schwarzy was ready for that then a great
shot hit by Kevin Hayes gobbled up by bla now
bla for Ley he comes in shoots it save R to
the rebound comes in front and the Kraken come
back with numbers Schwarz and burkovski here's
Schwarz to B kovsky settles it now the late man
windberger shot and it's saved by benington back
to feo s was wide open and didn't handle it then
veneers races in here he comes veneers a shot and
a great save by Bennington and the blues with it
and back and forth we go here's cyu Down The Far
Side wiad and Thomas back to Kyo Jes he scores
hyu and the blows have tied the game at one
Puck goes up the ice Jordan Kyu to Robert
Thomas and this is beautiful you see Robert
Thomas drops the shoulder just enough to
make everybody think he's shooting slides
it back and Jordan Kyra Wast no time with the
onetime couldn't get his Ms on it and now pass
the center what a pass and a two-on one Everly he
comes in and a sliding play by Paro to break it
up so teams at full strength to begin this third
period it is Thomas cyou and sod again bu davish
done for the night upper body injury so saw Tak
in his spot on the top line that's lob down the
aceo on defense with Nick ly and pra takes
cover back of the goal away from McAn as the
Kraken begin with their number one line on the
ice saw through the middle what a pass to kyou
he raises in in the circle shoots it and it GL
save by D Court it was a pretty good Nifty play
kyou and this is something Jordan Kyu can do
so well use his speed be evasive get a quick
shot on that 2 this morning they spent every
weekend hanging out together they spent some
time at Jordan bennington's wedding as well so two
good buddies entering Big Time contract extensions
as well going head-to-head here tonight at the
Enterprise Center good look at an opportunity
by the Kraken shot here bork strand just over the
blocker PA the pass play tries to get in he does
to the Middle With A Move play in on goal shoots
and it's saved by dor what a play by BL here Sammy
blle with a beautiful move inside out back outside
in gets in there let the cour with the sunru big
save of the Game Boy look at the myths on Sammy
blade silky smooth go stays an offensive player
or goal scorer you want him getting the puck
to the net as many times as possible and for
the blues Thomas kyou and F and then dropped
off to burkovski then he solders in he goes
wide pass in front what a save by Bennington
on lson we go back to Jordan Bennington for the
second game in a row gets across with a big pad
save fantastic job by the blues net finder kyou
trying to end it for Thomas he comes in Thomas
A backhander and A save by the cord As Time runs
out so Braden Shen against dor he's the first
shooter here he comes and a pad save by dor
looking to go to the other side on this one
draging it across the court up there with the
as he comes in last year's rookie of the
year against Bennington way out he waits
and a right P save by Bennington yeah this
is a tough one to lay off if you're goalie
look you think he's going top shelf there
nuh Jordan Bennington so goalis after one
round and now it's Jordan cyu up the middle
he waits and a glove Say by to cour by both
guys Jordan Kyu slowing the speed down waiting
a little Shimmy Shake there he was looking for
dord to drop the gloves never did as the native
of Denmark picks it up and he twists his way in
on Bennington waiting and a backhander stopped
by Bennington again he stayed with him at the
end if you're watching him here he waits Waits
Waits out comes the stick he lets the Cobra eat
a little bit the third shooter for the blues
see if he can get the blues ahead Thomas comes
in Thomas wading CH he scores Robert Thomas they
always have the ability to slow things down takes
a little bit of a route pulls it back save by
Bennington and the Blues win Jordan Everly he
comes in Waiting save by Bennington and the
blows win their home opener in a shootout